so is this now full-blown trade war and
where do we go from here we're here in
London The Economist and founder of a
quarter now it analytics dr. Rebecca
Harding is with me and in Washington I'm
joined by the former deputy director of
policy development at the IMF Desmond
Lockman will Rebecca let me turn to you
first what are the key products that
china is hitting him so China's hitting
soybeans which is big issue for the u.s.
also aerospace which is another very big
issue for the US so when the u.s. went
to when President Trump went to China a
few months ago he was very keen to
strike deals and a lot of those
aerospace deals and and that's kind of
emblematic of what the US economy is
concerned about doing these big
aerospace deals but the other thing is
that that soya beans is really big for
the American agricultural market so
that's going to create problems at home
for the president we don't know when
these tariffs were to come into effect
do we no we don't and I think the issue
is a lot of this is still in the realms
of rhetoric and we have to remember that
this is rhetorical to some extent so are
we in a full-blown trade war at the
moment you're seeing some diplomatics
diplomatic spats or some skirmishes on
the borders if you like a full-blown
trade war is when everybody starts
getting involved
well Desmond Lachman we've just heard
from Rebecca Harding there these are
quite surgical attacks almost by china
products like soybeans that really
strike at the heart of of the trumped
voting heartland absolutely that's what
they're trying to do they're trying to
respond in a measured way they're trying
to respond in a way that'll be very
harmful to trump in a political sense
but it's not in China's interest to
engage in a full-blown trade war the
thing is with China is they they have to
do something from a political point of
view so what they're doing is they're
responding in kind and there is time to
step back from the brink and to prevent
us from just drifting into a trade war
that's going to be in nobody's interest
so how do we do that how do we step back
from the brink
well there's a period before which the
American trade restrictions become
effective that there's still a couple of
weeks to go before that they're going to
be in place so one does have time to try
to find a way in which you can negotiate
a deal that'll be in the interest of
both parties I must say though that
Trump comes out with rhetoric that
doesn't give an indication that he's
hurrying to go down that that route in
fact he seems to be insisting that China
has to get rid of its trade surplus with
the United States by at least a hundred
billion dollars and that's not at all
something that is plausible Rebekah you
think that trumps using this as attach
it to get people to the negotiating
table rather than actually hitting like
they'll say so I think you have to look
at Trump's policies generally and when
he's gone on Twitter and stated
something about trade very generally
it's been something to bring people to
the table so he tends to take this
bilateral approach to trade I export
more you export less I win you lose this
kind of zero-sum mentality zero-sum game
is it well it's a zero-sum game if
everybody decides to embark on a on a
trade war then at zero-sum nobody wins
and I think everybody realizes that
nobody wins if we hit that particular
nuclear option but it isn't a zero-sum
game because the world is interdependent
global trade is interdependent and it's
shifting seismically so it includes
things like intellectual property in
these days but isn't there an issue here
that China could hurt itself I mean it's
the world's biggest consumer of soybeans
I think takes something like 60% of all
consumption and America produces 60%
where's China going to replace that lost
US production from so one of the
interesting routes for China is actually
Brazil Brazil exports an awful lot of
soybeans to China as well whether or not
it can completely replace the American
imports of soya beans is is debatable
but I think we all
we're going to see rhetorical escalation
at this stage there is a danger of this
spilling into a trade war through
political miscalculation if I can use
that but I do think that actually what
we're likely to see is people come into
the table and coming to some kind of
agreement because of damage on both
sides is to grades Desmond Lachman to
what extent I'm trade Wars
traditionally tend to hurt countries
that operate a trade surplus like China
like Germany do you think that mr. Trump
in a sense is holding all the Aces here
no not at all that a trade war isn't in
anybody's interest that countries that
are running trade deficits lose too we
get benefits out of trading and what
we're seeing is that Trump is having to
pay a very heavy price for all of this
talk about a trade war in that the stock
market is getting trashed that stocks
prices in the United States are down by
something like 10 percent since he
started the trade war so the United
States can get ready hit very hard
China will probably get hit even harder
it's not in anybody's interest what
Trump keeps saying that we can win a
trade war is absolutely nonsense it just
reflects complete ignorance of what
occurred in the 1930s when there were
absolutely no winners from a trade war
yes that lost value in the stock market
pretty striking now I mean can that ever
be worth it I mean is Trump making
noises about seeing that as being a
price worth paying
well if last year when the stock market
was going up he kept trumpeting it now
what we've seen is we've seen three
trillion dollars of value wiped off the
stock market in the space of a couple of
months that's something like 15% of the
United States GDP and wealth this can't
possibly be worth the candle and
hopefully what the market is telling him
it might influence the way in which he
behaves that's really our only hope that
he really listens to the market he sees
that this is a route to which he'll
really regret having gone down because
it'll be so damaging to financial
markets and to the US economy and the
global economy as well
all right Desmond Lachman in Washington
Rebecca Harding here in London thanks
both for joining me thank you